was die Leute doch hauptsächlich
verunsichert ist doch einfach dass sie
überhaupt dass sie spüren die Regierung
hat keinen Plan wo es hingeht also die
meisten machen sich doch einfach Sorgen
wohin steuert unser Land weil sie spüren
Deutschland steigt ab wirtschaftlich und
zwar ganz massiv es funktionieren ganz
viele Dinge nicht mehr meine wir haben
jetzt diesen PIs Test das deutsche
Bildungssystem ist in einem ziemlich
desolaten Zustand wir haben die
Situation Kassenpatienten warten Monate
auf ein Facharzttermin die Bahn ist nie
pünktlich also sind ja ganz elementare
Dinge 700.000 Wohnung fehlen und die
Regierung hat schon schon jetzt vor
diesem Urteil überhaupt keine Strategie
dafür gehabt jetzt kommt dieses Urteil
dann ist natürlich die Unsicherheit noch
mal größer ich teile das ja dass die
Schuldenbremse in der jetzigen Form
keine kluge Regel ist weil ich finde und
das machen auch die Länder die
erfolgreich sind natürlich muss man
Investitionen anders behandeln als
Konsum Konsumausgaben